let's flip it over to packers we got
plenty of time to talk about the super
bowl one of the biggest stories in the
nfl right now and even though some of
the media are doing their damn just to
shout it down it's taking root and
people are talking about it because they
recognize yesterday after the loss by
the packers to the tampa bay buccaneers
when aaron rodgers was speaking to
reporters he opened the door on his own
to talk about his future here he is
a lot of guys
futures that are
you know uncertain you know myself
included
uh
that's what's sad about it most
so how do you go on from here i mean you
can just hit on some of the realities
and benefits how do you go on from here
how do you how do you take the next step
yeah bill that's a good question i i
don't know i really don't uh
there's a lot of unknowns going into
this off season now
and
they just i'm gonna have to take some
time away for sure and
clear my head and
just kind of see what's going on with
everything
but it's uh it's pretty tough right now
you know the more i hear that the more i
see it the more i think about it the
more significant it is there's a lot of
unknowns going into this off-season i'm
not sure what the unknowns really are
nobody thinks the packers are going to
say well you know what we think jordan
love is ready aaron rodgers was slipping
a little bit last year it's probably
time to float him on a sheet of ice i
mean they want rogers they need rogers
and bringing jordan lovin actually gave
rogers a jimmy garoppolo style to tom
brady kicking the butt and helped
elevate him i think what the packers
didn't calculate is that rogers is going
to have some say in what his future is
going to be shireen and it seems to me
like
he's going to be thinking about
everything and i heard something just
before the show that
makes a lot of sense and we kicked
around this idea earlier today at pft
i think he wants more money that's the
talk he's woefully underpaid in
comparison to other top quarterbacks and
he makes as much as jared goff which
tells you how underpaid aaron rodgers is
if he's making either either jared goff
is ridiculously overpaid and he is or
aaron rodgers is underpaid and he is but
but that
is the core of this you get a new
contract and the contract carries the
security that you know you're not living
year to year you've got two or three
years of football left with the packers
based upon the cap charge that would
apply if something happened in the next
couple of years under a new contract
i'm going to take both my golf is vastly
overpaid and aaron rodgers is vastly
underpaid so i'm going to take both of
those because they're both true but
another thing mike
he may be positioning himself too to
have some say in personnel and what they
do in the off season
you know they drafted as you said moved
up to get jordan love they drafted aj
dillon the running back in the second
round these are obviously things that
didn't sit well with aaron rodgers in
the off-season he didn't feel like they
did everything they needed to do to
become the super bowl champion that they
now aren't going to be this year and he
sat there and watched tampa bay get all
these players every player that became
available tampa bay was all over them
and they ended up signing a bunch of
those guys and they signed a bunch of
those guys in season when you talk about
the leonard fournettes and abs and those
types of guys they were in on every
player they pushed all their chips to
the middle and said we don't have long
with tom brady so we're going to try to
at least win one championship with tom
brady the packers didn't do that for
aaron rodgers despite the fact that he's
running out of time as their quarterback
and they're sitting here with one
championship mike so this also could be
a play of hey i want you to do what
i want you to do in the off season
whether that's signing another receiver
to go with devonta adams or whatever it
is
upgrading that offensive line you know
by re-signing some of the guys like
corey linsley who's going to be a free
agent whatever it is
maybe rogers wants more say in that area
too mike and here's the problem although
it's a double-edged sword that could
help the packers as much as it hurts
them the salary cap is expected to be in
the range of 180 million for 2021
because of the pandemic that means there
isn't going to be a lot of money to
throw around but what it also means is
guys are going to be cut from other
teams
and if they're going to be getting
bargain basement offers and the middle
class for veteran free agents is going
to be non-existent it's going to be the
great depression for a lot of these nfl
players and they don't even realize it
yet
there's going to be guys available on
the cheap that you can say hey where you
want to play you you want to you want to
play for the ravens and never have the
ball thrown to you and i know that they
pushed back against that concept in a
press conference today with gm eric
decosta or do you want to come here and
play with aaron rodgers you want to be
part of what we're building here so
there is an opportunity if he can get
their attention and mike silver of nfl
network suggested that was part of what
he's doing he's sending a message to
brian gooda guticunce the general
manager that it's time to try to upgrade
the team i still feel like he's thinking
about more than that though when you
talk about your own uncertain future and
it wasn't accidental and it wasn't spur
of the moment and it wasn't emotional
he's smart enough to know there was a
good chance they were going to lose
let's say 50 50. 50 50 we win we lose
flip a coin who knows maybe a little bit
greater than 50 that they win but you
have to be prepared for that press
conference after a loss and i think he
may have rehearsed in the mirror a few
times what he was going to say and how
he was going to pull the pin on the
grenade that that we need to pay
attention to because we don't know
what's going to happen next and he's
made it clear he's going to he's going
to go think about things and at some
point he'll let the packers know what
he's thinking and they need to be ready
for anything from retirement which i
think is highly unlikely to trade me to
i want more money to i want more say to
some combination of those four
and everything that aaron rodgers says
mike is calculated he wasn't speaking
after a loss of i i know he used the
word gutted several times and i'm sure
he was gutted there's no question about
that but i'm just saying even then when
he's got it a lot of players would be
emotional after that and say things
maybe that they didn't mean or say
things that a week later they say well
you know it was just after a tough loss
no aaron rodgers everything he says is
for re he says it for a reason and it's
well thought out and it's calculated so
i think i'm with you he had this on his
mind before he walked in that room and
knew exactly what i was going to say and
mike he thanked the reporters for
covering him and covering the team this
year he's never done that before so
there were some things in this press
conference that were unprecedented
well and that's what caught our
attention what we do and i'm sure i've
mentioned this before the pft writers we
send around text messages saying we're
going to take this we're going to take
that if we see things that we're
interested in or we think maybe
interesting generally we'll paste the
tweet into the text chain and i started
noticing these texts that we were
passing around about
guys like jason wilty of espn wisconsin
who's covered the packers for years used
to do a radio show every week with aaron
rodgers when he says it sounded like
goodbye
that got my attention and multiple beat
riders who have covered the team for a
long time were saying this sounds
ominous this sounds serious this sounds
significant and last night after the
chief's bills game i watched that full
press conference we have a link to it at
pft you can go to packers.com and find
it's very it's very easy to find it's
there it's 12 minutes it's worth
watching and listening and reading his
facial expressions and how he chooses
his words carefully and i think he's
particularly upset about something we're
going to talk about coming up as it
relates to that opportunity for him to
to tie the game with two minutes and
change left that may be one of the
reasons why he was a little emotional
last night but
he
i agree with you sharing was not being
haphazard was not being reckless was not
being extemporaneous he knows what he
thinks and he had a plan
for what would happen if they lost that
game because he's smart enough to have
spent some time in a quiet moment over
the course of the last week thinking
this could be it we could lose and i'm
going to have to face these people and
what am i going to say and how am i
going to say it so now he gets thrust
into this conversation
which
you know last year was tom brady and
philip rivers well this year it's
aaron rodgers matthew stafford desean
watson we don't know what ben
roethlisberger is going to do the only
one we know is philip rivers he's
already retired drew brees we assume
he's going to retire uh dak prescott who
knows what he's going to do i mean it's
quarterback musical chairs potentially
like never before and i think it's all
fueled by the fact that
all these teams out there with great
young quarterbacks are set for the next
five or ten years and the teams that
don't have great young quarterbacks are
thinking
where can i get one and then the teams
are looking for just kind of a stop gap
are seeing these veterans out there and
they get fascinated by what they could
have for a couple of years and these
names are going to be
percolating and guys are going to be
moving and we just don't know how aaron
rodgers is going to fit into it but it's
definitely something we need to be
keeping an eye on
oh this is exciting mike i i can't wait
for this off season and you're right
last year it was the build-up to philip
rivers and tom brady where are they
going to go where are their best chances
to win
and now this year you've just got some
big names on this and this one isn't as
much about free agency as it is about
trades who are all these players going
to be traded to which makes it a little
bit more difficult a little bit more
complicated than just saying all right
well i think you should go here to
indianapolis because they have a super
bowl ready team well he's not gonna
most of these players aren't necessarily
gonna have their pick of where they go
deshawn watson obviously has a no trade
clause so he can somewhat dictate where
he wants to go but the best rest of
these players mike it's going to be
working out trades and where these guys
where they can get the best deal and
those are going to start fairly quickly
you have to have this done i would think
by the start of the league you're right
to know if you need a quarterback or not
oh absolutely now with aaron rodgers
because one of the things the naysayers
are saying is that there's no way they
would trade him because the cap charge
is more than 31 million dollars if they
trade him never mind the fact that the
cap charge if they keep him is more than
37 million and they'd save six million
in cap space by trading and jordan love
is on a bargain basement rookie deal
never mind that yeah but beyond that
they could hold aaron rodgers until june
2nd in the cap charge for trading and
this year is only 14 million in change
not 33 or 31 million plus and and
in a year where we don't expect there to
be much of an offseason program who
cares if you do the deal wink nod and
you tentatively agree and then you put
the paperwork in on june the second so
that's another element of flexibility if
that's what it comes down to let me just
say one thing before we move on to our
colleagues in the media out there if
you're watching first of all thank you
for watching second of all thank you for
listening to what i'm about to say
why do you want to knock down
potentially fascinating stories that
will drive legitimate interest in what
we do collectively we're trying to
engage people in our product we want
people to be interested we want them to
wake up in the morning and say i want to
check out the website of my newspaper or
pft or the athletic or espn.com or
wherever we want to see what people are
saying about this we want to know about
this we're very excited about this we
don't know how it's going to play out
i'm not talking about generating false
interest or click bait i'm talking about
turning your nose up
at an obvious storyline
that will help your employer generate
significant revenue
during what otherwise may be a quiet
lean month especially with no scouting
combine so
and i'm going to be even more blunt for
some of you folks out there that work on
a salary and when you get laid off you
wonder what the hell happened maybe if
you didn't turn your nose up at
potentially interesting stories your
company make enough money they don't get
laid off
okay i feel better
did i go too far
no
no it's a legitimate story line it's not
like we made this up mike he's the one
that brought it up in the press
conference if he hadn't said anything in
the press conference we wouldn't be
talking about this today
i i made a point in writing that was
fairly crass and i i i
it was so crass i'm not going to repeat
it if you want to if you want to know
what i'm talking about go to the pft
webpage press the search button and
search punch bowl and you'll find the
story that i'm referring to and the
point that i made
earlier today
as it relates to what aaron rodgers did
or didn't do
we won't know until some time goes by
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports